hey everyone this is kevin from
thechesswebsite.com and today we are in
game number two of the 2021 world chess
championship between magnus carlson the
defending champion
and the challenger jan nepo now on game
number one it was a draw yeah nippo had
the white pieces facing off against
madness crossing with the black pieces
so today we have magnus carlson playing
the white pieces trying to get on the
board with a win against nepo with the
black pieces so let's go ahead and get
into it magnus starts out with d4 then
after knight f6 we see c4
e6 knight to f3 and then after d5 we see
g3 so this is the catalan opening play
continues on the main line with bishop
to e7 bishop here to g2 if you're
heading to the king side here
castle on the king side castle on the
king side and then pawn takes here on c4
so this is going into the open catalan
opening where white's really looking to
give up a pawn in material for rapid
development control the center with both
of these central pawns here many times
black is just going to give that
material back so after queen to
c2 here you'll usually see black played
knight to c6 here
just say hey go ahead and take this pawn
here on c4 if you want to or even a6 is
a logical move as well netbo decides to
go ahead and try to hold on to it he
plays the move pawn to b5
and already early on in this game we see
a very similar style for magnus carlsen
saying i'm going to give up some
material here in this case a pawn
for a better structure on the board that
he thinks he can fare better in the long
game so we'll see if it works out for
him play continues with knight 2 e5
this opens up for a discovered attack
the bishop here on g2 is attacking the
rook here on a8
really really expected nepo to play
knight to d5 this cuts off this attack
from the bishop on g2 and it's just a
really solid structure instead plays the
move pawn to c6 and the reason i didn't
think we would see c6 is because i
really thought that magnus carlson's
next move would be just bishop take here
on c6 now i do recognize that magnus
carlsen prefers the bishop hair and
especially if he gives up upon a
material he's always looking to have the
bishop pair against his opponent so we
could have played knight takes here on
c6 but i do think bishop takes
bishop takes here on c6 knight takes
knight takes here attacking the queen
queen moves over here and then they
taking the bishop here on e7 attacking
the king queen takes and then pawn a
four
makes a lot of sense from madness
carlson but in this specific game
instead of taking this pawn on c6
madness crossing instead decides to go
ahead and play
a4
and only now do we see nepo play
knight 2 d5 it's going to be much worse
if
black takes on d4
because then we see the knight take
c6
attacking this knight knight takes on c6
bishop takes attacking this rook on a8
usually the rook's going to come here to
b8 and then pawn takes you can see start
to gobble up more material this rook a1
is attacking the pawn on a seven and you
can see there's also the threat of
bishop e3 attacking the queen on d4
maybe knight
d5 attacking this square here on e3 so
it's not very easy for white to just
play bishop e3 here
rook to d1 makes a lot of sense just
attacking this queen centralizing the
rook queen comes back here to b6 you can
see it gets pretty complicated for black
standpoint knight to c3 just developing
more material you can see all the
threats that white has on board here
black doesn't really feel or look like
he has many of his pieces working
together here so in the game after a4
black correctly plays the move knight to
d5 and also sets up for the night coming
here to b4 and then potentially over
here to d3 this would be a nice little
outpost eventually magnus carlton's
going to want to play
his e pawn pushing it forward usually
gonna be pushing in the catalan open to
e4 just trying to control the center of
the board and so at that point the
knight here on d3 will be a very good uh
outpost for that knight
we see madness crosston played knight to
c3 attacking this knight says yeah if
you want to go in exchange that's
completely fine decides first to go
ahead and play
f6 attacking this knight we see the
knight come back to f3 definitely better
than
just taking up here on d5 black does
have the double pawns on the c file and
this would just let black
escape from that and just take
on d5 you can see much solid structure
in the center of the board here now the
knight comes back to f3 pawn pushes
forward to b4 and you can see really
cramped position here from white
and so definitely not something that
masks magnus carlsen wants to do so it
does not take here on d5 correctly
instead brings his knight back here to
f3
now we see black play queen to d7 pawn
e4 as we talked about knight moves over
to
b4 preparing to come to the outpost on
d3 here queen over two e2
knight to d3 here and then e5 pushing
forward in the center of the board
bishop to b7 trying to control a little
bit of the light square diagonals here
pawn takes on f6
bishop takes here on f6 and then knight
to e4 attacking this bishop here on f6
we see knight to a6 and then the next
move is pretty interesting from magnus
carlsen
we're currently on the 17th move move 15
16 and 17 took magnus cross in 40
minutes now remember they only have two
hours for the first
40 move so to take 40 minutes on three
consecutive moves
in this stage of the game is not very
common for magnus carlsen but i'm
curious what you would play for white in
this position because his move is not
something that i would have come up with
and after he moved it
was quite funny i'll actually have a
link in the description below of nepo's
reaction to it he was blown away he just
kind of looked at the board like who am
i playing like who plays these moves it
was just so bizarre to him but magnus
carlsen played the move knight e five it
just doesn't seem
like a
normal move that you would typically see
in this situation but that's exactly
what madness crosston played again link
in the description if you want to see
nepo's reaction after magnus crossing
played knight to uh e5 here bishop takes
pawn takes you can see madness carlson
really likes the bishop pair against his
opponent that does not have that bishop
here so knight c5 attacking the knight
here on e4 that comes up to d6 and this
is going to be a great outpost for
madness carlson something that he relies
on for the rest of the game so he says
yeah if i have one knight i want to make
sure that it's the best knight on the
board he does have the bishop pair but
the other knight is very very well
positioned on this outpost this pawn on
e5 is protected by the queen so pretty
good setup for manish carlson here
knight comes down to b3 and this is one
of the things that jan was looking at is
the fact that once the knight comes to
b3 it just has so many threats and he's
going to end up winning material
and so after rook 2b1
knight takes on c1 rook takes and then
knight takes on c1 followed by rook c1
so you can see madness crossing giving
up material again
for what he thinks is a better
long game and gary kasparov
if you follow him on twitter or kind of
see how he's thinking about this
he's commentating during the game saying
these players just have no regard for
material because they're just giving it
away for these small incremental
advantages and that's exactly what
madness carlson's doing that's why he is
the number one player in the world he
just thinks about the game very
differently than everyone else
rook to b8
defending this bishop the knights
attacking it right now wants to make
sure he expects the rook to come over
here to d1 and that's exactly what
happens right now his queen is defending
this wants to make sure he has proper
defense here bishop comes to a8 and then
bishop here to e4 just centralizing the
bishop uh wants to make sure that it's
active in the game pawn to c3
queen over here to c2 does two things
one it attacks the pawn on c3 but also
prepares for the queen and the bishop to
attack this pawn on h7 nepo decides hey
that's a big threat i'm gonna go ahead
and play g6 just stopping the threat
coming over from uh white's attack here
with the bishop and the queen pawn takes
c3 pawn takes here on a4 but then
madness carlson is able to get one of
those pawns back in the exchange here
with queen takes on a4
rook to d8 just centralizing the strong
material with the rook and the queen on
the default rook to a1 here pawn c5
opening up to exchange the bishops in
the center of the board queen two c4
bishop hey nepo says yeah if you want to
go ahead and trade off that bishop
that's fine you know he recognizes how
much manuscripts and relies on those
bishops so he seems to be pretty happy
with exchanging those bishops knight
takes here on e4 and you can see getting
into the in game black does have one
extra pawn
uh but you can see that white has
or excuse me white has five pawns black
has five pawns but white has the knight
to the rook but that's where you can see
magnus carlsen uh not bit like others
this knight's going to be a crucial
crucial piece uh in this outpost here on
d6 so definitely favors from a material
standpoint black but anything goes when
it comes to the end game managed carlson
king comes over here to h8 uh just
doesn't want to have to worry about the
fork on f6 uh that would be disastrous
would definitely lose the queen here on
d7 so the knight decides to come back to
d6 just testing his opponent seeing if
he's still awake we want to make sure he
doesn't fall for any basic traps here
then you have rook to
b6 attacking the knight queen takes this
material here on c5 and then rook over
here to b8 king 2
g2 just want to make sure it's not on
this
first rank right here so there's no
shenanigans with the rook coming down
here to b1 uh at any point pawn two a6
then king to h3 rook over here to
c6 queen comes back to c4 king to g8
pawn to c4 so starting to push
this
pawn here on the c file a little bit
queen to c7 queen over here to
c4 preparing to take on
e6 if that opportunity comes up and also
checking the king on
g8 and now netbo decides hey this knight
here on d6 it's just i just don't want
to have to deal with anymore it's a
great outpost for the knight and yes a
rook is worth more material than a
knight
but sometimes a knight could be just so
well positioned that it's worth just
trading off and that's exactly what nepo
does so he decides to go and trade his
rook for that knight here on d6 so pawn
takes the queen takes and then after
pawn to c5 forcing the queen to you know
essentially take here then queen takes
on e6 check king to
g7 and then the rook takes up here and
you can see all of a sudden magnus
carlsen being down material the entire
game getting into the very
end game is now up a pawn in material
and looking to see if he can convert
this into a victory
now we see rook 2 f8 pawn f4
king 2 excuse me queen 2 f5 essentially
forcing the queen off the board
attacking the king and the queen here uh
so we see queen take rook down to f5
rook to a7 attacking the king king to g4
attacking the rook here rook comes over
here to e7 rook a5 and then rook to
e5 black decides obviously not to take
the rook uh and this is one of those
examples especially in the in game that
you should be practicing if black takes
here on e5 it does not matter how strong
your opponent is everyone should be able
to turn this into a victory so if you're
looking to practice positions this is
definitely a position to practice as hey
black takes here what does white do they
take with their pawn okay and then
they're going to just centralize their
their king here uh and then you know
there's just no good moves
that black has here you can see
if they play up two pawns then you could
just take here if they only play up one
pawn or one square you could play one
square as well and then they're in a
tough spot here so they're usually going
to have to
move their king away and then you can
just position your king a little bit
better eventually push up this pawn so
always know different positions on how
you can win in the end game
nepo very familiar with how to play
chess and besides it would be bad if i
lost this game so plays rook to a7 pawn
h4 getting into this position it's very
difficult for madness carlson to win
even though he is up a pawn in material
here
pawn h5 king over here to
h6
king h4
pawn to a g4
could have tried to just take material
here on
g6 king takes recover to
g5 decides instead to play pawn g4 this
does open up for the rook to come over
to h1 attack the king king two
g3 pawn takes here rook e6 check king g7
now pawn pushing forward so you know
madness carlson always looking for ways
to give up material to improve his
position so double pawns on the h file
is essentially like black giving up a
pawn in the exchange and it says yeah i
have these these two past pawns here or
at least one pass pawn here on the file
that this g pawn not passed yet but
decides hey this is a strong enough
position to at least try it's not going
to work out because in not too long we
do see the game end in a
draw so
fascinating game i mean came out the
blocks and both sides were looking
for blood and it did not disappoint
obviously i know a lot of you myself
included are looking for some big
dramatic wins but you can tell both
sides are going for it they're trying
different openings they're trying some
some wild sacrifices to give up material
for looking for some strong attack
that's exactly how magnus carlsen seems
to have faced both of game one and two
but so far we do have two draw somewhere
to 2018 where's a lot of draws we will
see tomorrow
with nepa playing the white pieces
how it turns out but thank you guys so
much for watching i'm really enjoying
this tournament some of the best chess
we've seen in a while so thanks for
watching let me know any comments or
questions you guys have in the comments
below and i'll see you guys tomorrow for
game number three
you